is it doctor again I don't think I could
do it again I do I need to do it now
when it's less scary I didn't want to
miss a minute
do it now do it now cuz it's gonna get
scary yeah it gets a lot one gets doc it
gets really [ __ ] up and weird do it
was that the whole is that the hole in
the wall
that's the crying oh hold on the ones
not there yet it's not there yet yeah I
thought it was always bad yeah I thought
the crying's gonna bring the bathroom
check those things on the floor it seems
like there'd be a piece of painting yeah
oh no no no no I think we've got those I
think we got that area already that's a
bug I don't know I can't see anything is
that picture the same yeah yeah I think
so yeah it's a more spider webby and I
think so it's fine she doesn't hurt you
yet but I didn't know that she would be
there dude look in there I think you can
probably leave the doors open right oh
dude talk to the bag I don't know still
nobody stole my bag it's fine it's fine
everything's okay everything this is
just a video game
yeah yeah progressively darkening video
game yeah we got that I'm the fact that
you slow time as well
I get sick I have to turn that's right
and my as I would turn in real life
mm-hmm I'm like the fact that you guys
don't look around the corner immediately
freaks me out I'm like what's behind
your back right now oh no nothing
nothing's gonna that's fine
bathrooms up doesn't open I don't want
to go in let's go I'm pretty sure you
get you a good flashlight at night go
look at the fetus go see you how fuse is
doing yeah that's your flashlight see if
every one of us yes oh right it's nice
it's really dirty mm-hmm too dirty it's
been--it's active No look at the fetus I
don't want just look look at it look at
it look at its little effects this is
actually not that disturbing to me no no
neither
I just find it kind of dumb it's kind of
good looks like hoff chicken hops we
look in the mirror I don't really want
you to either even though I'm pretty
sure nothing happens if you do look in
the mirror I don't know how to get out
of you I just like I forgot dude a bunch
of crap
maybe like zoom in on the oh yeah oh
zoom in on the hole in the wall is there
eyeball in there
no that's the hole in the wall that goes
to the hallway yeah
but it's it's like it's just like
reflecting your landing look at the tub
I really don't remember how to get out
again I don't fetus how do we get out of
the bathroom is it meant to be a human
fetus I think it's supposed to be their
warmed I feel like you know humans not
as deformed and faces I feel like it's
meant to be a chicken I think it's
supposed to be a thing that's bad it
just sits there
how many boobs do you think I ate too
many peeps I'm gonna broke too many
poops too many well look at the lotions
what kind of lotions are they it's a
nice lotion these you've got here is the
baby can you not baby can you not baby
shuffle baby Jess or maybe again I just
froze okay okay okay wasn't making that
noise before right it wasn't yeah maybe
you're supposed to be here for it oh god
it those things you know you know I've
been did open it opened it you know okay
are we still stuck in here no I'll go to
spider-woman
no nothing it's nothing but what but it
was just like a pigeon pooping did it
get doc oh yeah did it did yeah I think
I don't know [ __ ] look baby I don't want
to look up does this thing look poop
here than before
as always really shake himself Jesus
well it felt looks hungry hungry
butthole I hate this I hate it him no
friend if I wasn't a bathroom this dirty
of introduced by Paige
[ __ ] freak out I'd be like nope nope
can't touch a real surface find
something to kill myself with like
freaking all of this lotion you're like
hey I'm gonna OD on lotion chemicals oh
my pass out do you new thing happened
just go I don't want to do it just
really don't do it can do this along I
believe in you it's just everything's
drug doesn't need to smoke it's dark oh
it is darker don't you shut us down baby
wait a my flashlight go did I lose the
flashlight no I think you still have it
you're just in a litte
you sure down there where's the rest of
the picture how much of the picture do
we have I think that's like full pieces
that we still need for yeah yeah they
might before because there were really
small pieces is there one of them of
these pages I feel like there's gonna be
one in this end of the corridor oh yeah
somewhere maybe on the bottles
[ __ ] hell things are making noise I
hate this so much why are we doing this
I don't know Oh God
you wanna do something fun you want to
play PT that sounds fun
why did you lie to us I love being
scared oh my god no no you know I think
I might you might leave the room yeah
look at you no no nope
okay fine
you would look behind you why hell no it
helps you the know if the door is
[ __ ] open you go through that [ __ ]
does anything doors closed doors closed
doors closed remember the very there's
gotta be a piece of this picture on on
this desk here I think Jesus Christ
you're still talking man kill us are we
dead